we flew him all the way from austin
texas he's a former ufc middleweight he
is a special forces badass and a recent
new author
on today's food truck diaries it's tim
kennedy and i'm feeding him trapping
wings
[Music]
one of my favorite people in the goddamn
world make me proud to be american i
like being american yeah me too
yeah i think we're
living free because of people like you
my man well there's lots of people like
me so that's that's that's fun yeah i
don't know them though yeah i just try
to keep up with them because they're all
like big they're all like you they're
all giants they're all smart you know
they're all like good at things and i'm
i'm this hairy little troll that just
tries to hang out with you you're not
giving yourself enough credit because
obviously clearly you're a smart dude
you're on a book tour right now crushing
it by the way book's amazing
scars and stripes yeah i got lots of
both of those
but do we get the scars from fighting
yeah yeah dude i mean here this is
thanks to crow cop that's from cro
that's i get a nose job in croatia this
is jocko this is robbie lawler uh oh no
this was a jacare okay yeah and this was
robbie lawler and then like this was uh
michael bus no he didn't even touch me
you're not gonna give him the credit
but um yeah man i mean you're just doing
the damn thing i mean your book's
crushing it you're on this freaking pr
tour man
exhausting though
it's a lot yeah something like the first
week every day was like
16 to 20 media interactions
in a day so it'd be like a 20 hour day
sleep for four hours
so like i was like yeah write a book do
you really want to write a book but also
for guys like you i mean there's some
people who love it but
for you're like constantly talking about
you're promoting you know yourself or
you gotta it's like especially when you
have that many energies back to back
because i'm sure you're like me i'm like
i don't want i don't want everyone to
hear the same story but you gotta give
them the meat and potatoes yeah so by
the second day like yeah it's uh it's a
good special man you know i just tell
jokes it's like i just just watched the
goddamn thing yeah it's like yeah yeah
but important you know i get it the the
the book is it's a carrier for the you
know it's a cracker for the caviar and
the caviar is the same things that you
preach you know like we're trying to
encourage people to be better versions
than themselves like stronger healthier
like a fitter america a more prepared
america you know so
i just talk about all my failures all
the things i didn't do right that's my
takeaway from your book is i think
you know i didn't know what to expect
going into it but your book a lot of it
is about your failures which you really
don't i mean i don't know when you would
talk about it really but it's a lot of
like you being at some low points in
your life yeah yeah i mean it's
different you know you look back at your
your fight career and you see in the
octagon your hands getting raised you
won and everybody looks at that
especially current day in the curated
you know editorialized sense where it's
filters i look fantastic i get to show
all these photos where i look the best
but you know what they didn't see is
like you in the gym you grinding every
single day you would be like man i
cannot get up i don't want to get up my
legs hurt i have not recovered the coach
said hey you coming in let's do another
pad session you got spit coming out of
your mouth you know
like is that me or is that my gloves
but like that's what it is really like
nobody talks about those moments nobody
talks about the grind nobody talks about
the failures like i look back at being a
10 year old wrestling and losing my
first wrestling tournament getting
pinned in a single elimination
tournament and how ashamed and
humiliated i was i couldn't even look at
my dad you know i was like yeah you're
like gymnasium everybody's looking at me
priceless lessons so important those are
the moments that people don't talk about
but should be talking about especially
in the in this 2022 world boom that's
the key i think right now the reason why
you're booked like literally i told the
guys like you gave me a signed book read
the book but i told i forgot at the
house i'm like i told my guys to go hey
go pick up a couple books put them on
the table doing food truck like oh i'll
run up to barnes noble they're that 10
a.m right one open like dude there's
only one and it was in the like the
front for marketing and they don't they
sold out yeah i'm like yeah they're sold
out everywhere and i think
you hit it at like literally just the
sweet spot like right now americans this
is what we need man they need it you
know top guns killing it
and people are just like they're
starving for real experts they're
starving for truth they're starving for
transparency they're starving for
vulnerability they're just starving for
real people they're starving for
realness and they're starving for
someone that's made the walk lives by it
but it can speak on experience it's not
[ __ ] it's not marketing like we
don't need to create some hype sizzle
that this book is good are you doing
this stuff it's like you've walked the
walk and you're like man here it is
you know i'm dumb if i can do it you
know
you guys can do it
do you should write a book
seriously it's gonna be amazing i'll be
the first one to read it yeah i love it
man
yeah i don't know it's gonna be as good
as yours yeah i think uh it's just
perfect timing and like when you talk
about those low points in your life you
know knowing you and how positive you
are it's like holy i mean
there was some desperation there's some
wild there's a reason why you're like
this yeah you know yeah and it's it's
the litany of choices you know it's not
just like the superhero
decided to make this moment and that's
the that's the pivotal and all of a
sudden he tears his shirt off there's an
s and a cape you know instead it's like
lots of tiny little decisions that build
on top of each other slowly turning the
trajectory of where our life is going to
go for a long time i would be dying of
age i would be in prison you know i'd be
a multi-time felon for violent stuff
instead you know martial arts came in
there you know the military came in
there and those tiny little things
started making differences to ultimately
not make me do it be a total piece of
trash but do you encounter on this but
do you feel uh
any pressure like responsibility like to
get your voice out there because
i think you know for me whether it's
athletes some comics i look up to but
athletes i really don't because i've
been in that world but the people that i
gravitate towards are people in the
special forces that were the the elite
units the tip of the spare and i think
now especially in 2022 so and really i
think for the past i don't know maybe
five six years you've been doing long on
that but you guys finally have a
platform and people need this
information like people are dying for
this information before there's really
no outlet for you like you it's like the
secret society you know and then now
there's people like you jocko who can
give to the world and give this
knowledge where we might people most
people aren't special forces and can
never relate to that it's just you know
we can relate to some of it yeah it's
we're our own worst enemy the motto
special forces is the quiet
professionals so dear personal liberia
to free the oppressed which is pretty
irrelevant right now you know in like a
post-covered world liberators of the
oppressed but
we are our own worst enemies in the
sense that um we're not supposed to talk
about what we do like if you hear about
us doing something it's usually because
we messed up so it's ingrained in our
culture not to talk about it but i think
guys like you know evan and matt best
and jared taylor you know black rifle
guys i love those guys
from um
field craft survival jocko like all of
these
people have they know how important it
is for these
nuggets of wisdom and how relevant it is
you guys also have a special skill set
too though like you're a great speaker
like you're motivational like jocko when
he did the biden was like this is how i
would take ownership i we're watching
fine kid dude i was yeah i've only done
this maybe twice in my life i've during
draco's thing and then after the top gun
got done i had popcorn here and i was
like this during top gun obviously i'm
dude i want to run like jock
this leaf and he's like i'm going to
describe this leaf to you and the way he
talks i'm just like oh my god don't i
just dude he could read harry potter not
listen to that yeah he's jordan peterson
unconscious yes he's brilliant yes
jordan peterson another brilliant dude
who i could listen to paint yeah he
could talk about paint dry and i'd be
like i'm in
i'm in let's talk about uh sports
illustrated covers and i'm like i'm out
on this thing but usually i'm on board
maybe not topics
well before our cameras melt because the
120 degrees which i'm sure you've been
in way worse conditions but you weren't
expecting it here for food trucks no no
let's go to california now how can how
much can you eat are we worried about
your weight i know you got to run from
bad guys and catch bad guys i'm
currently just trying to hang on the the
mats with all of these monsters that
have moved to austin it's the only thing
my weight i'm concerned about is keeping
my cardio up but i worked out twice this
morning i would uh
i would there's a good chance i might
eat this dude's arm if he doesn't give
me a bunch of food i i think he's into
it it's the least you could do yeah it's
the least you do somebody give him his
your arm felicia all the [ __ ] he's done
for us all right well let me feed you
and continue this man i think it's
chicken wings let's do it let's take a
little break from talking to one of the
greatest americans of all time my boy
tim kennedy because listen
if you want to be tough to kill like tim
kennedy if you want to be in shape these
days but you don't want to go to the gym
but you want to get that sweating and
you're busy got kids you got work you
got all sorts of things going on
man you need the pellet tom that's how
my thick ass got into the bike world
i've had a peloton for six years now i
started riding my garage doing 30 minute
workouts 20 minute workouts tabitha's
with robin i love it now let's take this
to the streets next thing you know i
launched a bike club
i love peloton man and they have so much
uh to offer you guys listen they have
world-class instructors ready to
motivate you 24 7. all right they have
thousands of live classes which i
recommend but if you can't the on-demand
classes are ready whenever you want five
in the morning
noon 1 p.m
11 a.m whatever you need that on demand
class is there for you guys all right
and uh
whatever you need pelton gotcha man 10
minute upper body stretch between calls
you got a 40 minute run before bedtime
or like i told you the 30 minute tablet
program is my favorite right now is the
perfect time to try peloton the peloton
bike plus is now 500 less it's his best
price yet including free delivery and
setup and the whole delivery setup is so
fun it's easy as well uh and they have
more game changing prices available on
the original pelton bike which your boy
has they also have the peloton tread
which is the treadmill right you guys
know this visit onepeloton.com to learn
more that's onepeleton.com to learn more
and get you a bike now let's get back to
tim kennedy
[Music]
how you doing man
uh what do you recommend here man
appreciate you doing this it is hot as
hell out here yeah man so are these
wings so we're coming out of north
hollywood california i got some latin
inspired sauces i got a secret sauce you
guys got to try it's called sauce 64. i
also do uh buffalo fries i do a winged
burrito but uh you know everybody goes
crazy for the traditional what's the the
sauce 64 what kind of sauce we talked
about i know it's a secret but yeah it's
a little bit of everything spicy and
sweet you know you get a little hint of
all sorts of flavors so i recommend it a
lot that sounds nice what are you
thinking tim
they all sell the names themselves you
got like the baby mama i'm in on that
one og hot buffalo i'm in on that one
you know the honey sriracha absolutely
mango mango habanero so like should we
just do like a mix and you and i just
dive in like but a plethora like as el
guapo would say yeah like give us like
your five best flavors and definitely
the sauce 64.
like 10 of each and we'll just
no problem go go crazy yeah i mean look
like look at this guy we're not nice
yeah i definitely feel you on that one
dude this looks awesome yeah this is
fantastic that's what dude and uh i'm a
bone-in guy i don't like all nature i
don't trust people
same yeah what do you think when
somebody's like hey can i have a
boneless wings do you just look at them
like oh i'm like did you vote for come
on yeah what are you what are you doing
yeah first of all you can't be around my
kids no no like you just need to you
just get a little bit freaking almond
milk yeah can you sit at a different
table while you're at it yeah don't bone
in what we're saying sorry that was uh
we like to earn our meat you feel for
you guys
yeah thank you right now for you
whatever you think brother
that should do it man it's gonna be nice
uh we have drinks inside okay what the
hell is a dirty sprite
so a dirty sprite you know i mean if if
those you know who know the nickname
they know the nickname but it's just a
sprite with uh my secret uh it's like a
little mix of berries that i do so it
looks like a little another secret a
little um
another secret
drink so i have a certain set of skills
to get secrets out of people yes
yes and we do have water by the way okay
i'm not waterboarding yeah well no that
was insinuating like when you do
advanced
interrogation techniques but let me tell
you what i'll find it out
we get these secrets the sauce is that
good we're gonna come back
all right man appreciate it man all the
way sir yeah all the wings thank you man
it's on you
[Music]
all right my man let's try it now
they're they're bringing in more of the
special secret sauce that he's pretty
secretive about
yeah he like takes this off the camera
he's like here's if we're gonna do this
also the sprite um but uh
now last time you were on food truck uh
i won't say the name of the truck but
they were steamed burgers
and i was so embarrassed
as a texan if you were like hey i'm
gonna take this meat
and i'm gonna steam it what are we doing
you lost me i was out too i'm gonna take
moisture and water and i'm gonna cook
meat with it i'm like
i'm gonna take all the juiciness out and
just i get what he's trying to do i
don't trying to always trying to be
healthy oh gotcha that was the goal
instead of like cooking it on the grill
where it's cooking in fat literally you
know medium flavor yeah that's the stuff
flavor daddy yeah you know what i'm
saying like why do i like a rib eye yeah
come on do what we do so hopefully these
are better because that was a tough sell
but the uh
i always question the appropriate
etiquette and technique of eating
because you know deep throat that thing
exactly i mean
all right
it's good i mean it's solid hot whey i
mean it's hot salt hot one i want i want
it's tough to mess up the hot sauce this
is standard i'm gonna judge him based
off his secret stuff
his own recipes yeah because i can't get
that anywhere else well i think i mean
he made this by himself there's like
strong vinegar
it's good curly salt
salt fries um now for you
i'm surprised dude and i think i know
the answer i heard you talking to our
buddy joe rogan about this
i'm surprised you haven't gotten
involved in politics
now that being said hold on let me bring
that most politicians are narcissists
and crazy and you know but that's why it
might be good for somebody like you to
get involved but i don't know if
somebody like you can get involved not
be compromised like i don't know if you
can make the changes that need to be
made
well compromising is not really
in in my character don't really have it
in me that's why i'm saying but it seems
like to get anything done there you have
to make compromises
and i'm just not down for any of them
and um
but you you're like a rap like you deal
with a lot of it like
like whenever something happens like
clearly i'm not in the government or
politics but like with afghanistan
you're the i don't know i learn i don't
have the information the background of
it you're the closest person i know to
would have a great perspective so
i didn't give my opinion i text you
about yo dude like was it a bad idea
good and you broke it down for me i'm
like all right well then that's what i'm
going to regurgitate yeah there every
one of those problems are so complex
with so much nuance and like so many
different solutions um from
for me and like the organizations that i
work for civil allies for example you
know we just find a a problem
a niche that can't be solved by anybody
but us
you know
for example like the u.n uh afghanistan
during the withdrawal
you have these huge organizations
samaritan's purse like these are billion
dollar non-profits but they can't get
outside of kabul right they could land
in the airport or maybe they couldn't
even land they they couldn't
fund a plane to physically land in
afghanistan to get people out but they
had money and they wanted to do
something so they needed a specific
skill set of people to be able to go
not just land a plane in a combat zone
but then go out into the city into
into a war zone yeah
find people and bring them out special
skills yeah and then like in ukraine
when you look at the red cross or
samaritan's purse um like lots of people
are funneling tons of
humanitarian aid in but how much of that
stuff is making it to the front lines
well cool it's making the border of
poland
the border of poland is not under war
right now like that they're not the ones
getting bombed you have to go all the
way to the russian border where like the
nipro and the mirror pools
and that's super dicey that last mile
that's where save our allies
can you know take all of this stuff from
these huge organizations and go and
impact change and make sure it's getting
to the people need to get to because a
lot of these organizations i'm sure is
just like look we raised whatever 100
million bucks yeah we did our part yeah
yeah it's nice but you didn't do
anything yeah it's not it's not helping
them so without trying to get into the
politics of stuff i just try to find
work mr rogers i love this quote you
know when bad things are happening
he said always look to the helpers
there's always somebody
doing work
trying to help and uh and that's what i
try to do
in these big horrific moments where
school shootings um
afghanistan withdrawal
ukraine right now like what can i do to
actually make change make a difference
yeah politics is off the table for me
just because of some of my life
decisions yeah it makes sense but uh nor
would you want to be involved in that
but
i think too
for you like all these
topics you're talking about you talk
about you know ukraine talk about
afghanistan talk about mass shooters and
schools it's all hot topics like
triggering topics yeah like society's so
divisive on it you know so it's like no
matter what you do you're gonna get you
know these people upset or these people
ride for you it's like you're dealing
with like such touchy subjects if you're
paying attention to that stuff you know
or you don't can you just keep fighting
the good fight yeah i think i'll just
keep fighting the good fight and
you know i i think the majority i know
it feels like we're the most
separated and divided that we've ever
been
on social media yeah yeah exactly but
like when you actually get down to the
issues you and you're with people that
are trying to impact change
you have people from every walk every
religion every style of life being like
how can i help and that's been really
empower that's been really empowering
and encouraging
where it's
as most people felt disheartened
i just see
americans doing great things i'm like
this is this is awesome
because that's what i was going to ask
you because you go to some
you know
with what you do for for your job title
you know you see some pretty horrific
stuff you know some pretty desperate
dire times
i can't imagine because you're like such
a positive like happy person go lucky
person
it takes a special type of mindset to
deal with that stuff because like i had
a situation months ago where i helped
this family out that was in a car
accident the father tried killing the
family whatever i got the kids out of
the car
just me i had to go see a therapist just
the trauma from that really messed me up
and it made me so sad for weeks dude
yeah and dealing with what you see
i've seen as we come into them like i
can't like your mental space it must
just be
like either you're just
so
used to it and you know how to handle it
or
you know
you you're
do you see a therapist like how do you
deal with this because you see the worst
of the worst in the world but honestly
my my therapy is doing more work
you know i not that the greater good is
ever
because a great good could be used to
um justify and rationalize horrible
things but
like my approach is man if i if i can
keep going out and doing good and
impacting change and you know helping
americans and helping america's policies
overseas
and um saving more people's lives
when the plane's taken off from
afghanistan and i'm thinking about the
tens of thousands of people left behind
you're like that could kill you like the
women and children that literally have
to be like you have to stay i can't
bring you in no literally i had to tell
women that not for me yeah but i'm also
sitting on this plane on the c-17 i'm
looking around there's 400 people on
this plane and all of them for the first
time are breathing
a breath of
freedom not under the impending doom of
the taliban they can relax a little bit
you can relax and then i'm already
thinking like what is my next thing that
i can do what is my next mission that
i'm going to do you almost don't have
time to focus on that exactly just just
keep moving
you're like you know in a fight when um
the fight's not going exactly according
to plan
you know do i focus on the way that i'm
losing
no i focus on what is the the clearest
nearest thing that i can do figure out
the problem right and then start
changing hopefully that fight
dude i just love that your vascular arms
come in here and delivery system for
food big mark
it's taking a little break from chatting
with my brother from a very tough mother
tim kennedy cause listen
one thing about
today's society you want to be safe man
and you got to defend your home turf i'm
talking about your home man that's why
i believe your home should be the safest
place on earth for every family it
shouldn't cost an arm and a leg that's
why my friends at simply safe home
security got you covered man simply safe
is advance
home security that puts you and your
home and your family's safety first
here's why i love it simply safe offers
comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglars but
against expensive home hazards from
flooding to fires to get you covered man
24 7 professional monitoring simply
saves agents take action the moment a
threat is detected right they're
dispatching police for you first
responders in case it's emergency all
right even if you're not home they're
sending people because they want to
protect your crib man simply safe all
right they're the best
and uh it starts listen to this
monitoring plans are affordable price at
a dollar a day
one dollar to protect your home what are
we doing here one dollar with no
long-term contract or hidden fees
because feeling safe at home shouldn't
break the bank we got you man you can
customize the perfect system for your
home in just a few minutes at
dot simplisafe.com shop s-h-a-b go today
and claim a free indoor security camera
plus 20 off your interactive monitoring
system right go to simply safe.com
that's s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
simply safe.com
protect your crib
now let's get back to the program i was
really self-conscious today
i did that with one motion of my mouth
yeah gets as long as we don't look each
other in the eye yeah then you're good
because it's proud of you we lock guys
dude
bro you've done brother's country it's
the least i can't
my son he gives me one of those wings i
was like
boy there's a whole bunch more meat on
there like yeah i was like yeah i get
that dad but also yeah but also i don't
want to be too good with it also take it
easy man we can afford more weeds
yeah my girl dude she'll eat the
the cartilage the bones i'm like hey i
work too hard for you to bone the
cartilage like you're not you're not
sleeping in mexico on the ground anymore
like you're good man you don't need to
keep eating this is reasonable
yeah that's cool i'm not mad at it
there's not much more flavor maybe i'll
do that i mean you know we have more
wings here you know i mean i know i'm
sure you saw some dire situations in the
taliban stuff not there you're in
calabasas like you don't have to suck
the bone you have a dude that's going to
cook you all the wings that you want
yeah i know
yeah hopefully in the different flavors
you know over the different freaking
flavors but i gotta feel like your wife
when like
ukraine's popping off or afghanistan
your wife knows like she's watching fox
news or something like that it's just
like oh jesus christ yeah because they
know the bat signal is going up
daddy's gonna be gone for a few months
something will happen on the news
you know and like five minutes later my
phone rings and she'll just do this
thing she's like look at the phone
she's like look at me
i pick up the phone like i'm gonna go in
the other room she's like i mean i
already know what it is yeah see you in
six months yeah it's like are you gonna
just sit down and take it right now and
be like
ah but hello well she knows like she is
she's conditioned to it by now so when i
met her oh yeah i mean this woman she is
so badass
when i met her i was weeks away from
going and hunting the number one bad
dude in all of iraq zarqawi
i was literally like high-fiving part of
the special missions unit part of the
special forces task force to go hunt the
number two bad guy on the planet the
number one bad guy in the world that's
like when my wife and i were like hey we
good all right see you see you when this
is done we're coming back when the
dude's dead oh wow like that was the one
i see like i don't know yeah kill
capture mission when mission's done
leaning towards the kill there's
something that i'm sure she's attracted
i mean it's pretty hot and even i don't
know chubbed up right now
but there's definitely a degree where
like right now you know we have a leak
in one of the pipes and the modem
crashed she has the kids at home and
she's like you know maybe you could
catch some horrible disease and break a
leg and get stuck at home
just to get you get you stuck at home
but your kids are you because you have
four kids right yeah and they're just
used to dad leaving
they come with me a ton like they're
dead well not to like afghanistan
ukraine right no i mean like
poland's safe yeah i mean i think about
talking to you like i'm talking to my
wife mike so i mean trying to convince
poland's safe you know can you come to
crack out part of ukraine that's pretty
cool yeah can you like hang out with me
you know and like my family comes along
yeah and see that you're you're the
devil yeah that's what you are but your
kids are used to it by now yeah dude my
son's he had like stamped out his first
passport
before he was five literally
the life skills he's going to get is
yeah speaks fluent spanish you know yeah
my two-year-old like walks around she's
like
talk
somebody comes in and speaking spanish
and my two-year-old who's
probably as proficient in spanish as she
is in english like her eyes will light
up she's like finally a person i can
talk to loves it
would you uh
i mean obviously you're still training
you're rolling the monsters and
dana here
monsters yeah it's not good for the ego
ah it might be good though before you
get humbled right because that's all
they do though too you know like don't
shoot guns with them to be like what's
up dude yeah like there's levels to it
yeah so you know thank you can you go
hit but also there's you have a special
skill set won't you guys put 90 pounds
on your backpack and go let's run some
miles before we roll and see how that
goes i love where your heads are now i'm
saying but there's also a part of my
knife on the map where i get on the mat
and i go five rolls in a row
where
three of the rules i'm just trying to
survive
like literally i'm just trying to not
get you're six feet underwater yeah yeah
and then there's like the the gordon
ryan's where there's not even there's
not even trying to survive there's like
not trying to be so embarrassed and
humiliated by how much better he is than
you even though you've been doing it for
three times as long as he has
and it's like
yeah
that's not good
you're doing that how many times a week
no i'm still training ten times a week
ten yeah strengthen conditioning so you
got three cardio sessions three strength
conditioning sessions you know a couple
of boxing sessions couple of jiu jitsu
sessions now do you think you'd be
trading this hard against these top tier
guys if you weren't like fighting for
your life outside of jujitsu like you
you feel like you could at this level
you know what i'm saying like now if you
ask me to go roll those guys right now i
tell dick jokes dude
i do podcasts
no i'm good man yeah i don't know about
you i don't have that in me i'm like i'm
good i think i'm scared of setting down
the sword a little bit really yeah
you know i look at some of my peers that
have uh
metaphorically set the sword down and
they accepted the dad bod you know and
they um their wife doesn't do that
you know they don't look at she doesn't
look at him the same way i still want
that um they're sitting the sword down
but then also it's like
you're like you love to work out you
love to be fit yeah so you can set the
sword down still be jacked you know i
think for me for me they're pretty
intertwined like i want to you need a
mission yeah and i want to keep that
edge of being not just relevant you know
but also like i'm courtney rory mcdonald
right now
i love him so much and you know he's
fighting for the pfl in a couple of days
um
what kind of coach would i be if i was
like man well this is where this is how
i did it instead it's like hey come to
the octagon let's touch gloves and um
this is what i'm talking about about
pressure against the cage well see that
to me that goes back to your book on
like
and also you being like a voice right
now when america needs it the most
because you've walked the walk like i'm
not going to listen to some rich person
tell me i should vote or how i should
handle this situation it's like you were
born with a spoon in your mouth i'm not
gonna listen to you a silver spoon yeah
i don't really do any spoon i don't
relate to you in any facet you know what
i'm saying but you've walked the walk to
the same
your book the stuff you're doing with
this and then also with rory mcdonald
like rory's going to listen to it right
yeah [ __ ] jacques wright you fought for
world titles you fought you know
monsters bisbee you name it dude i still
plan it 65
one of my best friend shane steiner his
dad seven years old six-pack i mean like
ripped vascular strations honestly
or not no no he's like he he every day
he gets up he gets on the o he gets on
the water and um he spends maybe an hour
or two
wake boarding or water skiing and then
he'll come in and um like shane and i
will be doing some stupid workout and
he'd be like i'm just gonna hop in with
you guys
you're 70. i'm 70. 70.
and i mean that could be you that's that
is going to be me you know but that's
all he does
i mean he does whatever he wants yeah
question
if you have a
healthy f everything's easier when
you're fit right so he still does real
estate he still runs his businesses you
know he's still actively involved in all
those things and and that's what i don't
want to do is set down the sword lose
the edge both mentally physically i
don't think you can not then i can't
you're mentally it's not it's not in you
no you know what i'm saying
yeah i don't want to either i wouldn't
either there's nothing worse than when
you know you see a person who used to be
in phenomenal shape or they're at the
peak of their career with a comedian or
fighter act or whatever and they seem
like 10 12 years later you're like what
happened
there's nothing worse they think
themselves we step on the mat with danny
cormier in 10 years from now
is it still going to be frightening
yeah
you're like dead he's going to stay
coaching he's going to he's going to
stay healthy he'll be like getting a
little bit more around there dan i see
you know but the dude is still gonna
pick you up and throw you across the mat
and any which way yeah you know khabib
and 20 years from now oh nightmare he's
gonna be a nightmare but these outliers
like the mindset like i can't not work
out no matter what if i wasn't doing
this if i was on stage on cameras i
don't i just can't it's just not in me
yeah like on the comedy like that's a
that's a cognitive intellectual
exercise stand-up comedy that that i i
think is the most acute way you know via
debate or in in this era where
people aren't communicating where people
are not having any dialogue between them
or doing it 140 characters yeah you know
it's tough yeah but comedians you take
issues you break them down you find the
humor in them and then you reassemble
them and then you talk about them in
ways that are palatable by like that is
a really hard complex thing to do it's
tough as well especially in today's
climate too yeah there's some comedians
who are staying away from certain
subjects so dumb it's like no that's
that's why we're here man yeah like the
comedians need to be the ones that can
touch those subjects i want mel brooks
to be able to come back on again and
make
any of the movies that he like there's
no way any of the movies that he ever
made oh there's a ton of movies out judd
apatow movies won't be made no way no
way no what is happening right now
beside you
this was all i was waiting for
i was about to start looking up uh mel's
movies just until by time till the wings
came
all right so this looks like all right
that's the baby mama barbecue
that's the parmesan
oh here we go yeah uh so the sauce 65
well so you just label them and tell
which ones which looks it's pretty easy
though i would assume that's the sausage
before yep that's lemon pepper
mango habanero yeah
looks fire top to bottom right to left
all right it's like really really 64.
that's where you're going to start yeah
man that's what the guy was
said you know he like whispered us the
flavor
get down in there i'm just going to rub
the bottom
get it on the nose a little bit
oh it's spicy
i don't know we i don't eat
what is that no i wasn't expecting that
it's definitely a secret
it's nice at the end there is that black
pepper
that's where the spice is coming from
there's like sweet when it got on there
i just want to bite this guy who's this
skinny little dude i just walked in
we got wings for days for you
put some meat on you
before we try all these and sign out of
here
um next for you man just keep pushing
the book
saving lives
one more week book stuff
two days a corner and a fight and go
back over to ukraine
um spend a little bit of time over there
come back hopefully i'll get a couple of
weeks for the family and then uh
i have you know in light of the
the school shootings that have happened
uh we have a big
school safety program that's going to be
rolling out yeah i heard you mentioned
rogan yeah the best idea i've heard yet
yeah training lots of people making
schools tougher to access yeah harder
targets and all the while
uh trying to address the mental health i
think the the like the root cause like
address root cause make school hard
targets train a whole bunch of teachers
and police officers about actually what
to do
and then uh hopefully ukraine like
chills out a little bit maybe putin dies
i mean hopefully russia chills out yeah
they could just be like
yeah i hope they do just so you can
spend some time
yeah putin come on get out you're
ruining my my kid time with motorcycles
now how am i going to get a little cro
good at lacrosse if uh it's going to
take some time yeah switch to a kid now
do you ever watch fights when on this do
you ever watch fights like obviously is
he's the
style banners the the current champion
you ever watch him and think how you do
against him all the time especially him
right now i knew you did do you remember
when i watched him
sitting down the store and i can't do it
i watched him fight him like oh i could
hit him right now i could get inside
like stylistically it's a great
grappling your cardio could be some
issues yeah he he uh he doesn't like to
be in deep water he likes to set the
pace he likes to control range he likes
he's very good at controlling he really
is but like
joelle could have been the guy that put
the pressure on to pick some angles and
to mess with timing but he didn't you
all just like
hung back and fought the worst one of
the worst championship fights ever
complete nightmare for you like the
khabib style of you don't know if i'm
gonna take you down maybe i'm gonna hit
you with a big overhand right as i
change levels maybe i'm gonna come in
and push up kip's cage like nobody's
done that to him
they've tried right like brunson tried
some guys have tried it's just it's
easier said than done but he hasn't had
like a straight up grappler with a gas
tank that's closing the gap he's gonna
make it a dirty fight for 25 minutes
just knocked it a little bit gaslum did
but then and then he backed off and
didn't have the tank and then got lit up
great fight by the way one of the best
ones
of all time yeah so like yeah but you're
watching me like i want to get in there
yeah
and then i get on the mat and i get
reminded that i'm not not as good as i
thought i was yeah then yeah because
young kids are just like different level
man cause he's a monster yeah i'm gonna
eat all of these wings and you can you
can't eat those and the fries okay
don't say i can and then and then be
like okay we gotta go do this other
thing no yeah you have some time and
we'll have to talk to the boss man over
there you know he might have some wings
too can i put all this meat in my mouth
uh brian brian's vegan
ryan's vegan now though
all right let's close this out
we'll close this out so we can jump to
the next one you finished the wings
brother we love you here you know this
it's about time i've seen you oh yeah
you're now you're a tough guy now the
thing we do on uh food truck is all the
guests we give a sneaker to from because
i'm a sneaker head so all my my the
shoes come from my boys in suplex in
philly okay now you're an instrument
because you you know you're not
you know right yeah i can't just look at
my shoes and you're like i'm not gonna
even mention what you're wearing right
they're laced so tight like the [ __ ]
pops off you're ready to go yeah that's
the difference i'd be screwed seriously
if there's like gunfire i'm out the door
yeah they're tied so tight like you're a
marathon but it makes sense because you
you know you run for your life so these
now i have to get you a dope shoe and
i'm i'm hoping you're going to wear them
i told the guys i'm not too flashy send
me a bunch of ideas you can't do that i
can't do flashy but these so here it
goes mr kennedy please wear and enjoy
these kicks from the team at suplex we
thought these were a good fit for you
stop by if you're ever in philly
give their address
uh they're not crazy a little bit of
cameras those are awesome right yeah
those are nice and that's a that's tim
kennedy shoe we they said how about
yeezy i said tim is not a yeezy guy no
don't don't say kind of casual you know
can i could i dead lift in these sure
yes flaps absolutely yeah do whatever
you wanted could i ride a motorcycle
sure are they gonna be destroyed in a
week yes like you're a six-year-old do i
have to keep this white nope okay
because they're gonna get dirty i assume
that i wear lots of black because yeah
you can do it in these two
yeah thank you
i don't know if anybody's giving me
shoes before but these are great
thank you just wearing for me man okay
all right you know i love you brother
jim kennedy
[Music]
[Music]
i need everything i get super thick boy